[Music]
all right joining us now with more on
the outrageous story of this Oakland
Mayor warning residents beforehand that
ice agents law enforcement raids were
targeting illegal immigrants joining us
now Fox News contributor Tommy Lehren
and from Catalina magazine the publisher
Cathy Aroo is with us do you believe in
the rule of law Cathy of course I do
yeah and federal law says that you're
not allowed to enter the country
illegally right okay and for especially
in the case of those that are criminal
aliens that we know committed crimes do
you think it's a good thing that the
Oakland Mayor that she warns criminal
aliens in some cases Oh ice is coming i
want to aid and abet you for wouldn't
help you break the law we didn't say she
was warning criminal aliens I mean we
warned them ice is coming I wouldn't
call them criminals or aliens I would
say they were undocumented immigrants
like don't forget the words tax paying
family members illegal immigrants our
community did they break the law what
the country when they entered the
country illegally by not going through
the normal process is that illegal yes
sir yes or no I'm not saying they
entered illegally they may have had a
work visa when they were huge may have
been invited in by a company and then
decided about the people we know that
are here illegally you're being stubborn
now let's be honest there are people
that enter this country illegally some
people enter this country to legally and
people hire is that illegal
it may be frowned upon but I would say
undocumented I'm talking you know what
no wonder this is the party of it all
all the Pens of the meaning of the word
is is Tommy I can't handle this it's
obviously illegal the thing that bothers
me Tommy
that mayor is putting law enforcement
lives in jeopardy if I give them ahead
giving them how Shawn not only not only
law enforcement lives but American lives
residents of Oakland their lives are on
the line they talk about the Democrats
talk time and time again about they
don't want to break up families well I
would ask that
what about the families of Kate Steinle
and Jamil shod ii killed by illegal
immigrants what about those families do
those families matter you're putting a
lot of lives on the line in this mayor
if one of those illegal immigrants then
goes out and harm someone or god forbid
kills someone she has blood on her hands
so I hope she sleeps well it got the
answer Tommy dancer bones answered a
question about Kate Steinle well there
are so many people who have died at the
hands of non-hispanic white men in this
country so let's do for white men
finally be alive if there wasn't an
illegal immigrant that we knew was in
the country and could when millions of
people be alive if we didn't have white
men that were committing these mass
murders in this country they left deport
men let's deport me Tommy wait wait wait
wait wait wait
illegal immigrants have no legal right
to be here and now you're changing the
argument that we should deport white men
white American men because they commit
crimes let's talk about whether women
yes no legal right to be here they have
no legal right to be here they burn no
time contributing to their communities
they pay taxes or continue communities
one of them one of these individuals
doesn't contribute to their community
what happens if they harm or kill
someone
there's not always a bad apple it's
always a bad so let's get rid of every
contributor in this going in our
community every person that's with the
family helping their children every hard
worker because of one Apple
my blood pressure taught me help me laws
matter
all right laws matter and the mayor
knows our city the mayor knows her city
checkmate Tommy Lehren on this one